みなさん、こんにちは。このエピソードでは
、ドゴンによる日本語音声学の第3話へようこそ。
議論のために、日本語の方言のアクセントを勉強
しているときに遭遇する可能性のある2つの誤解について説明します。
高低アクセントとイントネーションという用語を
同じ意味で使用します。 ここでは、このレッスンの途中で個々の単語の高低音を非常に簡単に
説明するために、
少し複雑な用語も紹介しますが
、このレッスンの目的が少し圧倒されて
いるように思われる場合でも、あまり心配しないでください。
日本語の学習者は、この時点から
日本の音声学を説明するために使用する用語を定義しないため、注意すべき点を説明し
ます。
詳細な用語と
日本語の方言のアクセントの基本については
、レッスン5と6で説明します。
イントネーションはフラットなので、
日本語のイントネーションを勉強することは重要では
ありません。発音の問題だけです。
通常、2つのコンテキストがあります。 この
神話が発生するのは、最初は
東アジア言語としての日本語であり、2番目
は日本語の方言のアクセントやイントネーションを完全に理解
していないネイティブの日本人スピーカーと教師によって認識される日本人であるということ
です。
あなたはおそらくこれがどこに向かっているのか知っているでしょう
が、私はまだ少し時間を費やし
て問題に対処したいと思います口頭
言語はしばしば音色
言語と音色言語の非音調言語
に分けられ
ます マンダリン広東語ベトナム語やタイ
語などの多くの東アジア言語
は音調言語ではありません。日本語の
方言やアクセントがフラットであり
、発音について心配するだけでよいという誤った解釈をすることがあります。
これは誤りです。
一方、日本語の単語には
、マンダリンに存在するような音調パターンはありません。
またはベトナム語には明確な
高低
アクセントパターンがあり
ますこの英語は声調言語ではありません
が
、アクセントが間違った音節に配置されている場合、英語の単語にはアクセント
があります。 ああああのような声調ではありません
が、単語の高低アクセントがオフの場合
は奇妙に聞こえます。したがって
、日本語が声調言語ではないという理由だけで日本
のイントネーションが
フラットであると言うのは誤解を招きます。 音声システムまたはイントネーション
システム
英語の日本語が両方とも非声調であるからと
いって、言語学と音声学に関して同じ規則のセットを共有することを
意味するわけではないことを強調すること
も非常に重要です。
通常
、大学や採用されたカラオケのように単一のアクセントが特徴であり、
多くの
日本語の単語には複数の高低アクセント
のモラがあります または、Diagon COOや
Caraのような音節は大丈夫です。したがって、
意欲的な日本人学習者
は、コインの両面が
音調や
ゲームの偶数と奇数
が5分の1で死ぬので、非音調は両方とも奇数ですが、
日本語と英語が両方とも非
音調ファミリーにあるのと同じように完全に
異なりますが、要約すると1つの日本語は音調言語ではありません
マンダリンに似て
いますが、動的なイントネーションまたは高低
アクセントシステムがあります。英語と
日本語はどちらも非声調言語ですが
、イントネーションまたはアクセントシステムは
、日本人の
ネイティブスピーカー
や日本語を完全に理解していない教師が認識するように、日本語とは非常に異なるコンテキストです。
高低アクセントこれは少し
注意が必要
ですが、当面は用語についてあまり
気にしないでください。 全体的な議論に焦点を当てる
日本語で最も一般的な高低アクセントパターンの1つで、
すぐに詳しく説明します。
これ
は、単調な場合や変更なしの場合のように、フラットボードまたはフラットに大まかに変換されるヘイボンパターンとして知られてい
ます。
hey bong
パターンまたはグループの単語は、フラットなイントネーションまたは
ピッチアクセントを持っていますが、そうではありません。
または、Iとecoのように、
どちらもheybongの単語です。
ただし、日本語
のアクセントである劇的なダウンステップはあり
ません。これは
、次のレッスンですべて取り上げます。
ここでのポイント
は、ちょっとボンの単語に
は目立つアクセントがない
ということです。 低アクセントから高低アクセントへの変化。その
ため、この
パターンを非ネイティブスピーカーに単純に
フラット
として説明するのは危険です。これは、パターン名や、
日本語のネイティブスピーカーと言語の違いが原因で発生することがよくあります。 特に言葉が長い場合、専門家
や非ネイティブスピーカーは無意識のうちに
これらの言葉を認識し
ますが
、日本語の高低アクセントパターンはヘイボンだけではなく
、他のパターンで
は高低アクセントと
顕著なアクセントの例としては、高低アクセントや高低アクセントなどがあります。
これらの単語はフラットなイントネーションで言うべきではありません。
なぜ、
日本語のネイティブ
スピーカーが
生徒に日本語はフラットだと言うのでしょうか。
これは、日本語の教師が、日本語のすべての単語に
少数の高低アクセントパターンを使用するのをやめさせたいからです。これは、
音声トレーニングがなくても、ほとんどの
ネイティブの英語話者が
さまざまな高低アクセントパターンのすべてではなく一部を聞いて模倣できることを意味し
ます。 たとえば、日本語に存在するものは
、英語のネイティブスピーカー
が高低アクセントパターンを聞いて模倣するのは比較的簡単です。
高低アクセントの
パターンは非常に似てい
ますが、多くの英語の単語と同じではありません
isosaは辞書のよう
に聞こえるので、日本人の学習者がisosaのような単語を
聞くと、無意識のうちに
日本語の単語と英語の単語の
高低アクセントまたは
イントネーションパターンが似ていると思い込みます。 彼らの脳は
、このパターンは確かに日本語に存在すると
言っていますが、問題は
、ネイティブの英語話者
が何らかの音声トレーニングなしでは通常は聞こえない、または模倣できない
高低アクセント
パターンがたくさんあることです。
英語を母国語と
する人は、AI tsatsa、
Tibet、tomatoなどの聞き取りと模倣ができるパターンをすべての日本語の単語にマッピングします。
カクは
、カクの代わりに、先生がその単語にアクセントがないと言って修正することが多いと言います
先ほど
説明したように
、高低アクセントはありませんが、この単語にはアクセントがありません。これは、アクセントなしに
つながります。はいいいえ
アクセントはフラットに言い
ます。はい日本語のイントネーションはフラットな
会話
です。 通常、
日本語の方言のアクセントを明確に説明するためのツールセットがすぐに利用できる
ので、生徒
が間違った高低アクセントで長い単語を言うとき、
日本人の教師は
、日本語がフラットであると言う方法を知っている唯一
のことをすることがよくあります。 日本語のより一般的な高低アクセントパターン
であり、ほとんどすべての単語で
1番目または2番目の音節を強調するのをやめさせたい
ので、日本語のイントネーションはフラットであると言うのは誤り
ですが
、この誤解が存在する理由を理解するのは簡単です
。 日本語のネイティブスピーカーは、この
誤解
はある程度は役立つものの、やはり過度に一般化され
ており、最終的には私たちのphoを制限していることを認識しています。 ネティック
能力は、個々の単語ではなく、文全体や文に関してもフラットと言うことがあることに注意してください。
私は
個人的
に、文レベルでも過度にアクセントのある日本語のルーツは、
主に
前述の
理由に起因すると信じています。 これ
については後のレッスンで詳しく説明します。神話第
2の異なる日本の方言は
異なるイントネーションパターンを持っているため、
日本人が出身地域に応じて異なるイントネーションパターンで同じ単語を言う場合でも、日本のイントネーションを研究する必要はありませ
ん。 ですから、イントネーション
を勉強することは重要では
あり
ません。完全に理解するために正しい標準的な日本語を持っている必要はないという意味で、このステートメントには真実が
あります。イントネーションや高低
アクセントのパターンは方言によって大きく
異なることも事実です。 しかし、
この議論を通常行うほとんどの人がすること
ユニークな方言で話すネイティブスピーカーが
一貫してそうしていることに気づかない、言い換えれ
ば、地元の
方言で話す日本人は恣意的に関西方言に切り替えることを恣意的に強調せず
、そして
-声明の途中で東京方言
または、日本人の
ネイティブは方言と意味の
一貫性を持って話すので、ピッチアクセントを研究しない非ネイティブスピーカーの違和感の欠如から切り離されることはありませんが
、多くの場合
、ネイティブ言語のピッチアクセントパターン
を日本語にマッピングします
東京方言のように聞こえる言葉、
関西方言のように聞こえる言葉など
、日本語の方言によって
イントネーションパターンは異なりますが、ピッチ
アクセントパターンが
1つのセットに統合されるまでは、ある程度不自然に聞こえます。
これが、私が通常推奨する理由です。
方言を勉強し、方言
を使う地域で留学する
学生 oalは
、教室の外の別の方言で、教室で標準的な日本語を勉強するアクセントのようなネイティブを開発し
ています。
日本語にはアクセントリストの方言がありますが、
フラットな
イントネーションだけを使用するだけで、そのような方言を正しく話しているように聞こえるのに十分であると考えるのは誤り
です。
どこから来たのか、または方言が
平均的な日本人のネイティブスピーカーにどのように聞こえるかを知らずに、特定の方言で
話そうとすると、
すべてを音響的にフラットな方法で言うことで、
すぐに話せる日本語が改善される可能性があります
が、 同時に
、あなたの最終目標が開発である場合、それはあなたをキノコ農家のように
聞こえさせるかもしれません 印象的な普遍的に
理解できるアクセントを使う私は
標準的な日本語をお勧めしますこれは
おそらくあなたがすでにそれを勉強して
いるからです-それは高度に文書
化
されているためです
あなたが好きな、または深いつながりを感じている特定の日本語の方言は
、その方言の3つの方言を追求することを思いとどまらせようとはしませ
ん。 その方言で非常に高度なレベルに達するまで
、ピッチアクセントが多少断片的に聞こえる可能性があります。
これはすべて
主観的ですが、たとえば、一部の人々
は、より関与できる
ことを意味する場合、わずかに断片化された方法で話すことを好むかもしれません。
その方言を話すコミュニティそれは
トレードオフについての
すべてですこれがtになることを明確にするためだけにこのレッスンのためのすべての大丈夫な人
彼
は私がYouTubeのレッスンに完全に投稿した最後の日本の音声学の
レッスンであり、Beyondは
月額10ドルでサポーターのための
パトレオンの独占的な
コンテンツになります。
今すぐサインアップすると、シリーズコンテンツの大部分に対して、約
50〜60ドル、または
新しい元気教科書の価格をわずかに超える価格
が支払われます。 アップロードさ
れたのは、常連客が多ければ多いほど、
コンテンツをより速くプッシュできるので、近い将来、レッスン4
でお互いに少し遊んでいる可能性がある
と思います。
音声認識と有用な音声
プラクティスについて説明します。 レッスン5
日本語のイントネーションまたは高低アクセントの基本を紹介し
ます。音声学を補足するために使用できるさまざまな無料のサードパーティツール
がcomになります。 その後少し経ち
ますが、今後ともよろしくお願い申し上げます。